how's orphan black changed my life I was
over black not changed my life I was
over my change in my life it's changed
my life in so many different ways not
only career-wise just being able to walk
into rooms that I would never normally
get to walk into I had no idea people
were killing off clones I had no idea
people were making clones and then
killing them and it's not right it's not
me to dig down and realize that there
there's goodness and humanity and and
something worth fighting for and
everybody I just don't think that I was
an actor before the show like I know I
was an actor obviously I auditioned and
um and I had worked before but I don't
think that I had fallen in love with or
been open about how much I loved acting
orphan black was my first on-camera job
so I've been able to learn for five
years under the most amazing mentor I
could ever ask for and touch Anna we got
to make a show for people that didn't
have as much of a voice on television
and that means everything to me well I
got loads of free shoes and Friday so
I'm sorry good for boots forever I'm
pretty sure that clones are people to
like I think technically they're humans
so let's stop killing them orphan black
has changed in my life
because it has shown me the power of
fiction when you get people who are real
geeks and nerds for storytelling and
character they actually can change
people's lives if it can push back the
sometimes oppressive boundaries of the
norm if it can make one person feel
better and prouder and more open about
their identity that I think fiction has
deserve its highest purpose it's
unbelievable that the that this thing is
now so important to so many other people
the clone Club has been like
life-changing in terms of hearing
stories from people about how the show's
affected them the best supporters the
most loyal fans they keep growing and
growing and creating art and it's
inspiring to see their reaction to what
we do I never thought I would work on a
show where people testified that the
show changed their lives which is the
most astounding and rewarding thing
about it giving them a voice given them
a conversation starter for coming out to
their parents we're a show for outsiders
and for people that were marginalized
because of who they chose to love who
they were attracted to or what color
they were and we took all those
characters and Outsiders and we put from
center stage and gave them a venue to
fight and stand up for themselves and
I'm very proud
[Music]
I was orphaned by change Norrish I made
lifelong friends
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]